you spent some time with your extended
family recently right I did yeah we you
know I grew up outside of Chicago in a
little town called Manuka and every
summer we take all the kids including me
and go to the Cubs game which was a huge
deal big deal yeah and so recently I I
was invited to throw out the first pitch
and sing the seventh-inning stretch
oh my god which is that's a big honor
yeah blew my mind it was so crazy so we
took 23 family members on a bus up to
the game what you guys like rented a bus
and we did we rented some sort of Vegas
party bus yeah or it may have been a
funeral bus I don't know much different
so this is a big big family gathering I
think you brought a picture of your
whole extended family though there are
the offerings in the Roberts
you know what's with this guy here he
doesn't seem that thrilled
that's that's my dad it's worried
because there was no one left he he
might have just been read the riot act
by mom sitting next to him yeah he gets
gassy on buses all right all right
mm-hmm
it's more than I wanted to know see you
threw out the first pitch and you sang
take me out to the ball game yeah okay
those are two things you gotta do which
is the scarier one to do well I had seen
Harry Caray do it so many times I was a
little nervous but once I got up there
in the booth and they walk you through
the organ stuff that seemed like it was
going to be fine I had had it in my
bones the pitch stepping on to Wrigley
Field was a little crazier and and so I
planned some stuff out with my dad he
came out and we did some some Buster
Keaton silent movie comedy for the crowd
wait a minute
instead of just throwing the pitch you
did a little like a silent skit
beforehand well sure I mean what do you
mean well sure no one does that I didn't
think they were inviting me for my
pitching prowess so you know I wanted to
give him a little bit of a show yeah so
we did we did some comedy and then and
then I threw my pitch and it sucked
yeah so I was glad I got did people but
people at least laughed at your bit did
anyone give you a hard time it was funny
I you know I said well god that was fun
and crazy and the catcher is about a
quarter mile away and eight feet below
me from that mound but you know through
the pitch it made it to him yeah which I
think is worth some points and I said
well that was fun dad and we were led up
to our seats and a couple of drunk fans
got to their feet as I passed and said
what the hell is that supposed to be I'm
a jackass throwing out the first pitch
yeah yeah well we we have the footage of
the little we have the footage see today
and we we gave it a little treatment to
make it look more like a real silent
film oh that's cool let's take a look
[Music]
I'm a comedian
that was a that was a great comedy pitch
yes it was
[Applause]
you